Ok, I can drift you over this.
Let's go push this.
Ok, uh...
Ok, we can start here.
So starting off, I think I went a little bit too fast
and probably could have kicked a little bit higher
a little bit more flexibility.
This point felt pretty smooth.
I think I was relaxed.
Went a bit too quick there.
Should have done a little bit of a pause.
This point, I felt pretty smooth here with this.
Kick, I could have done a little better,
but again, form is what I'm thinking about.
And each time I think about how I could have done better
with that form, I just move on.
But my mind has been completely clear.
Keeping sure I make a good count
with every...
form or technique here.
So, I think too bad.
I feel like most of this was...
I was going a bit too fast,
but overall, I kept my pace
and good count.
And yeah, I think...
Overall, I think the experience was
around in the middle.
Very mediocre.
Not too great.
Not too bad.